jpmorgan chase is by far the largest
traditional bank in the us and one of
the most well-known and respected banks
in the world
many people despise chase because they
are quote-unquote too big to fail
meaning that they can get away with
nearly any financial mistake but how big
exactly is jpmorgan chase
well at the end of 2020 jpmorgan chase
reported their total deposits and client
assets to be a whopping
5.926 trillion dollars
but just a decade ago the bank's assets
and deposits stood at less than half the
current amount at 2.8 trillion
and whether you respect the company or
not this is an extremely impressive
figure and the man behind this
phenomenal growth is none other than
jamie dimon so here's the story of how
jamie dimon became the 5.9 trillion
dollar banker
taking a look back jamie dimon was born
on march 13 1956 in new york city to
greek immigrants
if you're familiar with european last
names you might have noticed that
jaime's last name diamond is not a greek
name but rather a french name the
family's original last name was actually
papa dimitrio but jaime's grandfather
decided to change the name to diamond in
order to sound more french his
grandfather was also a banker who worked
in athens and i guess he thought that
sounding french would make him more
trustworthy i'm not quite sure but
anyway going back to jaime it looks like
he had a pretty nice childhood as his
father was an executive vice president
at american express jaime ended up
attending the browning school followed
by tufts university where he majored in
psychology and economics during his time
at tufts jaime wrote an essay about the
creation of cheerson through a plethora
of mergers at the time shirsen was the
second largest security firm on wall
street and jaime's mother would mail
jaime's essay to sandy wale who was the
leader of shearson sandy offered jaime a
summer internship at the firm which
would eventually turn into a two-year
stint as a management consultant jaime
would end up returning to school though
to pursue an mba from harvard business
school it looks like jaime was a star
student at harvard given that he would
end up graduating as a baker scholar
which means that he was in the top five
percent of his class during both years
of his mba in between his two years at
harvard jaime also picked up a summer
internship at goldman sachs considering
his education and all of these highly
respected internships i don't think
you'd be surprised to hear that he had
several job offers waiting for him when
he graduated in 1982. these offers
included goldman sachs morgan stanley
and lehman brothers
but jaime ended up choosing american
express even though they offered the
lowest salary of the bunch sandy whale
had moved over from shearson to american
express and jaime had the opportunity to
work with sandy again at american
express which jaime valued more than the
higher salaries at the other firms
between 1982 and 1995 jaime worked as
sandy's assistant and when sandy left in
1985 jaime would follow him to his next
venture sandy had his eye on a failing
consumer finance company called
commercial credit sandy acquired the
company and took a private and appointed
jaime as the cfo
over the next few years jaime and sandy
bought a couple of smaller financial
institutions that were in a much better
state
this included primerica financial
services the life insurance company a.l
williams and the brokerage firm smith
barney
following the acquisitions the duo
implemented a cross-selling strategy
which meant that each entity within the
parent company would buy services from
another entity under the parent company
whenever possible
this minimized the total outflow from
the overall company and vastly improved
the financial state of the parent
company
by the early 1990s commercial credit was
doing so well that jaime took a stab at
acquiring a failing institution called
travelers insurance
in september of 1992 travelers insurance
was on the brink of bankruptcy because
hurricane andrew had just devastated the
bahamas florida and louisiana which
resulted in a massive influx of
insurance claims
it was a rather risky bet though as
travelers insurance was not a small
company coming in at 5 billion
but if they could stay solvent after the
acquisition the new company would be one
of the largest financial services firms
in the u.s
jaime and sandy would not only take the
risk but they would also take the name
travelers as the brand was far more
recognized both in commercial credit and
primarica around the same time the duo
would acquire shearson for 1 billion
dollars which is quite ironic given that
jamie was just an entry-level intern at
the company about 15 years before this
all of this was just the beginning
though as sandy and jamie were about to
create one of the largest banks in the
world and i'm not talking about chase in
1997 travelers would acquire the famous
investment bank solomon brothers for
nine billion dollars
this was the second largest acquisition
in banking history at the time but the
merger that would take place the
following year would blow this deal out
of the water
in 1998 travelers group made a deal with
citicorp to merge the two companies
both companies were valued equally at 70
billion dollars meaning that the new
firm would stand at 140 billion dollars
and that's how modern day city group was
founded the chairman of either company
sandy whale and john reed became co-ceos
of the new company and jaime was
appointed as the president of citigroup
jaime was only 42 years old at this
point and he was already the president
of one of the largest banks in the world
but unfortunately things weren't as good
as they seemed on the surface sandy and
jaime had gotten into a bit of a
misunderstanding the story goes that
sandy was salty that jaime didn't
promote sandy's children up the ranks of
the company sandy expected jaime to
point his daughter jessica as the chief
of asset management and his son mark as
the leader of the solomon bond business
sandy was about to retire in the next
couple of years and the expectation was
that jaime would take over as ceo but
sandy feared that if jaime became ceo
his children would be left in the dust
so sandy felt that he had to make a
choice between his adopted son jaime and
his real children jessica and mark
honestly i feel like this was a pretty
unfair expectation i don't think jaime
was against promoting jessica and mark
by any means he just wanted them to rise
up due to merit as opposed to family
connections sandy obviously disagreed
with this dance and at an executive
retreat sandy would ask jaime to resign
from the company when the news broke
that jaime was resigning wall street was
shocked
apparently when jaime stepped onto the
solomon smith barney training floor
after resigning the 1000 traitors in the
room gave him a standing ovation clearly
jaime was a highly respected man in the
industry and there was no objective
reason to fire him
it should also be noted that jessica and
mark would end up leaving citigroup so
sandy's decision was utterly pointless
jaime was unfortunately not able to
become the ceo of cd group but we all
know that it would end up playing out
even better for jaime jamie didn't
instantly get another job though he
would take a 18-month break from work
and he would actually consider retiring
jaime says that he was very open-minded
about the situation he had plenty of
money so money wasn't a concern
all of his children were quite young so
he considered staying at home and
raising them jaime also received plenty
of job offers from leading companies
jeff bezos actually offered jaime the
position of amazon president
if jaime had taken the job he might have
been amazon ceo today but jamie decided
against it deciding that finance was his
bread and butter when the opportunity to
save a feeling bank came up though jaime
knew that this was his calling jaime
took on a job at bank one as ceo and
chairman in march of 2000
at the time bank 1 was the 5th largest
bank in the us but they were getting
crushed during the dotcom bubble the
bank started losing money in 1999 and in
2000 they would end up losing 511
million dollars so clearly the situation
was not good the first thing jaime did
was buy 2 million shares of the company
because he thought that he would be more
motivated to save the company when he
had money invested after that jaime went
on a waste reduction purge he cut
relationships with bad partners shut
down the unprofitable online division
and he made branch manager compensation
based on net revenue as opposed to total
sales
jamie was able to save one billion
dollars and make bank one a respected
financial institution once again and
soon enough jaime would land on the deal
of his lifetime in january of 2004 jaime
would negotiate a deal with jp morgan
chase to complete a merger of equals
citigroup had become the world's largest
financial services firm and the j.p
morgan chase needed the merger to
compete against citigroup so they would
agree and the two companies would merge
in june of 2004. jaime was originally
appointed as the president and ceo of
jpmorgan chase however once the ceo
william harrison retired in 2006 jaime
would move up to being ceo and one year
later he would become chairman as well
unfortunately the 2008 financial crisis
would roll around the following year and
jaime was at the home when chase was
quote-unquote bailed out the media often
likes to paint chase as needing the 25
billion bailout that they received but
this is really not the case jp morgan
chase was the strongest of all the
american banks in fact they didn't even
have a single negative quarter during
the entire crisis
jaime says that the only reason they
took the bailout is because the u.s
treasury wanted them to the treasury
felt that if chase took the bailout
smaller banks who actually needed the
bailout would feel more comfortable in
taking it as well
also chase paid back the entire amount
just one year later in june of 2009
around the same time jp morgan chase
also became the largest american bank
overtaking cd group and with that jaime
had become the largest american banker
this time jaime didn't get screwed over
by chase
in fact he would be extremely well
compensated and even become a
billionaire in 2015
but unfortunately he would be hit with a
new set of problems in 2014 jaime was
diagnosed with throat cancer and he had
to go through radiation and chemotherapy
for several weeks and just last year
jaime nearly died after his aorta
exploded the most ironic part of this
terrible experience was that when jaime
caught a taxi to go to the nearest
hospital after feeling severe chest pain
the taxi driver drove him to will
cornell medical center which was of
course named after sandy whale
fortunately the doctors were able to
repair his aorta with the seven hour
surgery and jaime was able to return to
work the following month today jamie has
until 2023 as ceo at which point his
term expires
he'll likely have the opportunity to
extend his term for another 5 years
but he's already chosen some successors
so jaime's time at chase may be coming
to an end very soon
do you guys think it's about time that
jaime got out or do you think that jaime
was a phenomenal ceo comment that down
below
also drop a like if you respect jaime's
devotion to banking and of course
consider joining our discord community
to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hurry and i'll see you guys on
the next one